[Music]
the content of this program is to
provide nutritional education only this
program is not meant to take the place
of your primary care physician the FDA
requires us to let you know that our
products are not meant to treat prevent
diagnose or cure any diseases as an
empowered individual you have options
available we are honored to have one of
the founding fathers of epigenetics here
to guide us with the best options to
obtain or maintain Optimal Health Dr
Joel Wallach welcome to daily with Doc
and Becca
[Music]
thank you
hmm
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
the content of this program is to
provide nutritional education only this
program is not meant to take the place
of your primary care physician the FDA
requires us to let you know that our
products are not meant to treat prevent
diagnose or cure any diseases as an
empowered individual you have options
available we are honored to have one of
the founding fathers of epigenetics here
to guide us with the best options to
obtain or maintain Optimal Health Dr
Joel Wallach welcome to daily with Doc
and Becca
foreign
[Music]
thank you
and we are live with the intro so Dr
Wallach take it away
okay well thank you Becca and thank you
team okay and some it's always a great
day
um Monday through Fridays we're here
sharing and helping people
I love that part that we're helping
people
and we don't charge them for our
services we don't charge them for our
services so uh it's a double good all
right now what I want to talk about
today is a a variant on osteoporosis
skull most people don't realize it'll be
your jaw and your TMJ your temporal
mandibular joint uh allocated where you
have a joint where your your job hooks
in your skull
is all part of the skull okay and you
can have problems with your TMJ joint
you can have problems with your teeth
and gums when you're a kid a lot of kids
you know their teeth get loose they
start wandering around and so they go to
an orthodontist and they put braces on
them when you're older
um your teeth are all loose and falling
out and so they pull out the remainder
of the teeth there that are loose and
won't make it for very long and they
either do implants
okay of fake teeth are give you dentures
that you can take out at night and put
in in the morning and so forth and these
are all signals that you're getting
osteoporosis of the skull because this
is part of the skull okay
and so it's one of those things where
you really have to pay attention to the
details just brushing your teeth in the
morning and evening won't cut it okay
that's nice but just think about all the
people who've had to have dental surgery
jaw surgery
Dental Replacements all kind of stuff
they're brushing their teeth okay that's
because they weren't paying attention to
the skull and of course we have the book
it's on your head now CD goes along with
it and
um this um
set was put together by
um
myself and Milan and Rebecca and then
huh
I've got it up you can put yours down so
your voice isn't muscle okay
and so
um
the top picture is a picture of the
skull
right and you see this is normal they've
taken the calvary and they've taken the
skull cap off so you're looking down
onto the brain and you can see that the
skull is a quarter of an inch thick the
second picture below it okay is
osteoporosis of the skull and they've
taken the calvarium off they're looking
down on the brain
and this is the sort of stuff that's
going on with Bruce Willis right now
he's got T was it uh
um
MTD he MTD he's got um
um the the brain stuff going on
where he's having the the front part of
the brain the temporal part of the brain
uh being squeezed okay and going away
because he has
hello
somebody's breaking in and talking
excuse me Dr Wallach go ahead
block yourself please
you don't want me to block myself no the
other people
oh okay
all right and so this is something that
is ongoing
um most people think your bones are
poured concrete you get your bones and
you got your bones and you know
eventually they're going to go away
sometimes they go away faster than
others well that's not true
your bones are Dynamic living tissue and
they come and go based on what you eat
what you don't eat
okay and if you're eating gluten wheat
Brown oats and you're not taking the 90
cents nutrients which is required for
your skull and your jaw to function
properly and and maintain healthy
um
anatomy and physiology it takes a lot of
nutrition to do that and if you can't
absorb it because you're eating gluten
because your intestines are dead you
have a problem so again we want you to
get this book in the CD set it's on your
head that will get to the information
there's 37 different diseases you can
get including TMJ temporal mandibular
joint disease okay you get all these
issues
there's again 37 different diseases you
can get and when you have osteoporosis
of the skull and some of them are not
really very good because you know you
can get very aggressive behavior like I
had when between ages five and nine 20
doctors couldn't figure it out today
it's called Tourette Syndrome back then
they didn't even have a name part
and just recently about two months ago
now or close to two months ago now the
book the wallet Revolution that was
published this is a second edition and
has put together originally by a
team okay
um
and of course they're not individually
named but they they
um because they didn't want to be noted
for this so their uh a collection of
doctors and lawyers and business people
and so forth and they call themselves
the committee and they put it together
and we're so very excited and happy
about what they did and then we decided
there was other things we could add to
it to to launch it into a greater
broader audience
which we did and it's available now as I
guess Becca's holding it up the second
edition
we actually have this this is the part
that makes my heart warm we have very
famous people okay like Pat Boone
um let's see here
um also uh let's see here
who else Danny Glover
Danny Glover
yeah Danny Glover right and then we have
Andy young Ambassador United Nations and
and also he was the
um mayor of Atlanta and then we have
people like um
oh let's see here
we have the story of Theo Ratliff Theo
Ratliff right Theo Ratliff
um here's a guy you know who had all
kinds of trouble uh with his joints and
and this and the other we rebuilt him
and he tells how we did that with
nutrition yeah there you go that's
that's Theo and he came back he could he
had to give up they didn't give it up he
they fired him because he couldn't play
properly because of all his joint bone
problems including skull
we rebuilt him using the um
what we now call the healthy Brandon
hard pack origin was called the healthy
Bone and Joint pack and that was built
for him he came back and he played
professional basketball for 11 more
years made a hundred million dollars
and so his story is in there same way
with Evander Holyfield if Andrew
Holyfield lost his Heavyweight
Championship he had to default because
he had a heart attack and he couldn't
answer the bell for the last round so he
lost his championship because he had a
heart attack we came up with a healthy
brain and heart fact for him
and he took it and then diamonds there
he came back and destroyed Mike Tyson in
the sixth round and got his Heavyweight
Championship back now who comes back
from a near fatal heart attack to win a
heavyweight championship fight you got
to be kidding me so these are all the
things are in this book the wallet
Revolution but it tells you why it tells
you what's needed here and why we were
in trouble why we're in trouble and if
everybody were to follow the information
in this book The Wallach Revolution
we can save millions of lives a year in
the world we can save an enormous amount
of unnecessary misery and save an
enormous amount of money for individuals
and families and insurance companies and
everybody else and insurance doesn't pay
for nutrition
insurance doesn't pay for nutrition they
only pay for prescription drugs and
surgery and that kind of stuff
it's really sad because nutrition
can prevent diseases and cure the
patients and so
um right now you know everybody's got to
pay their own way through
but if you're if you're a customer with
youngevity
you get
um uh wholesale prices okay and then if
you get an auto ship I will pay the
shipping so you save a lot of money
there if you do this as a business out
of your home
all your costs your personal supplements
that kind of thing also the space you
use in your home your utilities on the
same percentages
Insurance same percentages and so forth
your car are all tax deductible and then
first Rebecca and her teammates they all
know about this and they get these tax
deductions and and so forth because
they're using their cars and their
houses and their offices and in their
homes and so forth and getting the tax
deductions as well as the benefits of
the nutrition and so this is something
that it gets you Tears In Your Eyes we
spend three trillion dollars a year the
tea three trillion dollars a year in
America alone just to treat the symptoms
not to prevent a cure but just to treat
the symptoms
of osteoporosis and arthritis in America
we spend three trillion dollars a year
it all goes into the doctor's pockets
okay
626.8 billion dollars for arthritis
which is obviously a process of the
joints and 2.3 trillion dollars to treat
the symptoms of osteoporosis combined us
three trillion dollars
oh my gosh
and of course and the doctors aren't
working real hard to find a better way
they're just staying with that system
because it's worth three trillion
dollars to them
so we think we have found a better way
to prevent and reverse these diseases
including what's going on with the jaw
okay and densis Dentistry
um
and it's one of those things where
Dentistry starts in kids with you know
when they go to these uh doctors who do
braces for kids all right and it's one
of those things where it's just really
sad that just for a few dollars you can
actually prevent all this and reverse it
get back to normal
the skull
is something that has a capacity to
repair itself when you have osteoporosis
of your knees doctors want to do double
knee replacement you have osteoporosis
of your hips the doctors want to do a
double hip replacement you have actually
approach this year skull we're going to
give you a double head replacement
come on no and so basically what we've
got to do here is get this information
out there so this it's a
what should I say it's a a movement it's
a flood of the um
the average person
everybody has a skull and everybody
should ask their Physicians is there
such a thing as osteoporosis as a skull
they will laugh at you and slap their
knee and say who told you that there's
never been a report
and osteoporosis of the skull
okay
well there's 37 different diseases you
get from honestly approach to the skull
I'm not going to say anything else but
you get the picture
okay if your income is coming from that
slew of diseases why would you want to
change that you just treat it
okay and so
um I'm not going to go any further but
you have your own ideas and you can
understand I think what I'm saying so
TMJ is no different than arthritis in
your knees TMJ is no difference in
osteoporosis of long bones in your legs
and arms and vertebrae and all that kind
of stuff
and so you start you know when you're a
kid
and you continue doing this as you're
going through puberty and you continue
this as you go in later life and
particularly in women if they're going
to have kids or they don't even think
they're going to have kids you still you
never know you go to a party you never
know what's going to happen and so you
need to make sure you're taking all your
90 essential nutrients and stay away
from the bad stuff so you can maximize
absorption and that's why we came out
with a book Dr logs cooking without the
bad foods 300 pages of safe
um recipes
okay and also save cooking methods
and then all the nutrients you need to
prevent reverse
these diseases why do you want to spend
626.8 billion dollars a year just to
treat arthritis obviously opposed to the
joints why do you want to spend 2.3
trillion dollars a year just to treat
the symptoms of osteoporosis
no no no it's a lot cheaper just to take
the vitamins and minerals
it's not cheaper to cook properly
and stay away from the bad stuff so you
can absorb no gluten no buckwheat
no phagopyrenes
and buckwheat and Fable Pyrenees cause
lupus oh it's autoimmune your body's
attacking itself that's when we came out
with the book
epigenetics which is a summary on my
book that's in the Smithsonian Institute
that's me in
1976 when I discovered the first
non-human cases fibrosis and a monkey
supposed to destined for space with NASA
okay and they fired me because I said it
wasn't genetic and they fired me and it
was a terrible terrible beginning but in
the end we prevailed because now
we know what causes
um
these problems okay and so we can we my
attorney John nemour and I just on that
one subject
we sued the FDA eight times in federal
court got these nutrients put into
the Enfamil Similac and the like and we
eliminated cystic fibrosis in kids and
other birth defects we eliminated
mustard dyspeed and Jerry Lewis knew
that for a couple years before he died
and there's one of those things where he
was so excited he took the information
to the Massachusetts Association they
fired Jerry Lewis and put a gag order on
him so he couldn't say anything to
anybody because he brought them the
cause wrench and a cure for most history
and then it also wound up preventing
Senate syndrome so I'm the guy who's
responsible for getting rid of
cigarosis muscle fee
um
see here also the son of a death
syndrome
you don't hear about those things
anymore because they're in in the baby
formulas I'm the guy that forced them to
put in there with my attorney John
anymore
all right and doctors are saying for
years and years and years and years
that sentiment death syndrome was caused
by the mothers laying on the babies and
suffocating them
just a simple nutritional deficiency
Okay so
this is an endless story it's an endless
story and I'm so excited about it we
have all these tools now okay and of
course we have 10 CDs big CD Set uh 10
healthy Secrets your doctor doesn't want
you to know about these are 10 zooms we
put on CDs okay it's a pharmacist Keith
Abel and myself so it's from Pharmacy
and nutrition from the Nature Valley
doctor this is a great set it's flying
out the door
okay and then all these young athletes
dying okay there's a new bowl in town
okay all these young athletes dying
there's three CDs in here the average
life expectancy professional athletes in
America is
um let's see here
57.3 I think it is okay
and we have the CD
um let's see here dead athletes don't
lie we have the CD
uh let's see here's exercise on
supplementation suicide you see this
every week there's all these 20 30
um and um 40 year old athletes they're
Olympic athletes they're professional
athletes they're
just people who exercise because they
think exercise alone is good well
exercise a lot of supplementation is
suicide because you're sweating and we
already talked about that in another
earlier program I mean it's what you're
not just sweating out water and drinking
water after exercise to rehydrate
doesn't cut it and that's why we came
out with the rebounder his first drink
with 100 nutrients in it our rebound has
75 metals and 25 vitamins and amino
acids in it whereas Red Bull has one
mineral magnesium
and I think they did that because that
was the middle of choice of Bruce Lee
who's considered the fitness Guru
by every country in the world in the
1960s and he died at age 32 of a heart
attack in 1973 because he's only taking
magnesium what a terrible terrible loss
he was such a wonderful man a terrible
story he was getting a lot of
misinformation because he was asking
doctors
what do I need something I just eat well
you get everything you need and he
believed the doctors which was
essentially the cause of death on his
suicide on excuse cause of death on his
death certificate would be followed
doctor's instructions that would be his
cause of death okay so with that we're
going to go over to Becca and find out
if we have any questions
well we have lots of questions Dr
Wallach but I do want to let people know
that it's the citizens committee for
better medicine that wrote the original
of this book that Dr Wallach has now
made their
unauthorized the authorized
biography of a medical genius
and there are lots of stories there's
dozens of stories of people's
testimonials including the research so
it starts out with the research and all
that Dr Wallach has done and through all
that he has done
he was given the cloud Schwartz award
for his work with the selenium and just
minerals and how they are so closely
linked to deficiencies
so you have done a lot Dr Wallach and
where you have gotten some recognition I
don't think that it's far enough and
that's why we're doing what we're doing
to make sure that your message that has
been helping millions of people
continues to grow and grow and grow well
to me that's that's the best reward
I could possibly have there's no
that the information is helping so many
people
yeah absolutely well we do have several
hands up Dr Wallach so let's go ahead
and move on to hands and the first hand
that we have is Barham go ahead and
unmute yourself
hey guys uh it's nice to speak to you
again
um everyone Dr Wallach
hello hello so Dr Walling I have a
question about my cat
if that's all right
go ahead
sounds good so I noticed two months ago
that he has an issue pooping when I saw
it it was really hard and dry like a
rock and he licks himself a lot he'll
lick you know the other cat I have uh
and see I'm wondering um what might be
dishing with them okay stop there what
are you feeding the cat
so dry food
uh until I switch to what food listening
to you guys and knowing that I can pour
like Arthur decks and other things in
there that I'm gonna eat
so what is a combination of two you know
I would give him a canned
cat food that's moist and also arthrodex
would be one one scoop I don't care if
the cat only weighs eight pounds I'd
give them a full scoop of the arthrodex
okay
and um make sure that there's no table
straps where there might be
contamination from gluten or buckwheat
or anything like that
and so again I'd go with a canned cat
food and the arthro decks
um and wouldn't hurt to have a special
bowl for drinking water and put a a
ounce of our plant derived colloidal
minerals in a pint of the drinking water
in that dish for the cat to get us
drinking water okay
okay
okay then possible in a couple weeks
thank you thank you so much you bet
all right thank you and Dr Wallach I
wanted to thank Mark who wrote in about
bone loss in the jaw and wanted to know
if it was from osteoporosis which as you
are sending in your emails and questions
people this is where we get the
information of what you want to know
what is the greatest concern so please
go to daily withdoc.com you can sign up
for a newsletter and submit your
questions there and know that even
though that there is a store on daily
for Doc with
daily withdoc.com if you were
specifically invited by somebody get
back with them they took the time
because they care make sure that you get
back with them and thank them for caring
and ask them if they have a special way
that they order their products and how
they can help you get what you need also
so thank you so much Mark for writing in
about that and while we're on that Dr
Wallach what would be your full protocol
so he has been told that
and this is by a university Dr Wallach
that they want to do bone replacement
operation of his jaw
because he's got loose teeth
he doesn't want to lose his teeth well
this is a nutritional deficiency okay so
he's got to get rid of all the bad foods
and again him get that book doctor
always talking about the bad foods 300
pages of safe recipes and cooking
methods absolutely no fried foods no
processed Meats by processed Meats I
mean hot dogs bologna salami pastrami
pepperoni jerky corn beef Spam ham bacon
got nitrates and other chemicals in
there shouldn't have then no oils no
cooking oils
absolutely no frying oils and all that
kind of stuff no salad dressings
absolutely no
um gluten no wheat nobody round oats
well my doctor says eat a lot of whole
grains well change doctors okay
get that book Dr lunch is cooking about
the bad foods whole grains when you're
talking about wheat bun around oats they
have gluten in them they kill your
lining of your intestine which reduces
your ability to absorb nutrients by 98
even if you're taking them people say
yeah I took vitamins and milk didn't
help me any what'd you eat for breakfast
every morning oh I have oatmeal for
breakfast I've had oatmeal for breakfast
my whole life well that's why you're not
getting any results because your
intestines are dead and even though
you're taking all these nutrients
they're going into the septic tank
coming out the back end
okay so you have to be able to absorb
these nutrients and so no gluten no
wheat no Baran oats no buckwheat there's
no gluten in buckwheat but buckwheat
does have phago fago Pyrenees which are
worse than gluten and then no sugar of
any kind and then absolutely no
carbonator drinks and we're talking
about alkaline water and carbonated
water
um and we're talking about you know just
carbon just carbonated water people so I
don't even drink soft drinks I don't
want all that sugar and caffeine or
anything I just drink carbonated water
well carbonation in the water
neutralizes your stomach acid so you
cannot absorb minerals or digest food
you have to have stomach acid the good
lord gave your stomach the capacity to
make stomach acid but you do require
certain nutrients to make stomach acid
and it's called
salt
so we do have the salts okay from
Australia okay this is a cell from
Australia because it's the the seasoned
salts okay from Australia every once
while we'll get the Himalayan salt
and so these things are exactly very
very important okay
um salsa has two required nutrients both
of them require every cell in your body
sodium which has all have to do with the
metabolism of the cells and all that
kind of stuff and then chloride what is
your stomach acid hydrochloric acid made
from Salt so if you're not salting your
food you're eating gluten
and you're not supplementing you're in
deep trouble because you're you're
killing yourself from three different
directions okay this is not difficult
is actually very simple okay but you
have to pay attention and do all the
good things and stay away from the bad
things every meal every day every year
of your life and it was always that way
but it got worse at three o'clock in the
afternoon Monday September 4th 1882 in
Pearl Street New York City in the Bluff
Road looking construction bridge when we
went to electricity
and it was not so bad that even the U.S
Senate figured it out okay in 1936 the
U.S Senate came out with the usn
document 264.
in 1936 they said there's no longer
sufficient amounts of nutritional
minerals in our farm cells to support
long and healthy human life
okay because it was like
18 years okay after electricity started
we were getting started to get all these
diseases nobody ever seen before and
that's when doctors came up with the
false concept that they were caused by
by genetics and autoimmune factors okay
because they didn't know what it was
caused by it's caused by just simple
nutritional deficiency and they didn't
know that they still don't know that
they don't get taught any detailed
nutrition in medical school they just
say well just have meat well bring
everything they need that's absolute
nonsense
all right thank you so much for that Dr
Wallach and next let's go to Jill who
has her hand up Jill go ahead and unmute
yourself
hello there hi Dr Wallach hi how can we
help you
can you hear me
can you hear me okay yes okay thank you
um I have two different questions the
first one is I have a new customer she's
70 years old she's five foot four and
she weighs 147 pounds uh she has uh high
blood pressure and she started taking
just the regular healthy body start pack
including the liquid Osteo and I started
her slow because I always start
everybody
um you know on smaller doses the first
couple days but
um even with that her blood pressure
spiked and she said that normally it's
115 to 120 over 77 and she does take
blood pressure pill but she kind of
monitors it and changes it based on what
her blood pressure is doing but she said
when she took the regular healthy body
start pack at a smaller dose it went to
165 over 95 which was higher than she's
ever been and she said she doesn't feel
well if she if her blood pressure is 150
over 90. so right now she's only doing
one scoop okay
okay now she can't stop taking her
medication so that may have been part of
if she reduced her medication or stopped
taking no she didn't she didn't but
apparently she takes anywhere between a
half a pill and a pill she didn't change
how she takes her medication she's just
telling me that
um what she does take the blood pressure
meds and with the blood pressure meds
that's where it usually ranges okay well
she needs to add to this program okay
the ultimate daily classic challenge the
three words ultimate daily classic
tanders and her body weight she could
take three twice a day and they will
help reduce her blood pressure and help
blood flow through black Tories but
don't pull turkey obviously often for
medication but as the blood pressure
begins to drop it's going to slowly
reduce the medication there's something
going on there where maybe she ate you
know oatmeal for breakfast that morning
and didn't absorb or who who knows okay
that just that doesn't sound right to me
no I know I understand I mean I I don't
don't disagree at all that it could be
something that you ate but she reduced
it and so now she's only doing one scoop
instead of two of Beyond Tangy Tangerine
2.0 and half announced of um Osteo
liquid Osteo effects but she's still her
blood pressure is still higher yeah
until she takes the ultimate daily
classic tablets
okay
so which of the two products do you
think is spiking her blood pressure the
uh the BTT or the Osteo I think she
probably cut back on her medication she
said she didn't yeah I think she cut
back on her medication because I treat
thousands of people
okay with the healthy brand hard pack
and they never have a spike in their
blood pressure that's what I told her
and that's what I thought she's got to
be doing something weird by stopping
taking her medication or something like
that you don't stop taking your
medication when you start our program
okay but as the blood pressure begins to
come down you're going to slowly reduce
the medication based on the numbers so I
suspect that she just took our stuff and
then stopped taking the medication as
wise fight okay
thank you
the second question is I hear people all
day long that have been told by a doctor
a nurse a friend whatever to take
magnesium and they're looking for just
magnesium not calcium and magnesium and
what's your thought about that okay well
they take magnesium only because they're
listening to Bruce Lee who is a fitness
Guru and also
um that's the the only mineral
that Red Bull puts in their horse drink
yeah and so they think that is the
mineral well don't do that you need to
take them all okay you we require 60
different minerals
okay that's why our sports drink rebound
has 75 minerals and Red Bull only has
one magnesium
okay that is the stupidest thing I've
ever heard okay so they're telling them
to take it to sleep they're telling them
specifically to take it to sleep and
they're looking for just magnesium and
I'm telling them no it's calcium
magnesium vitamins
it's more than that it's more than that
it's all 90 essential nutrients and this
is this is a problem when people say
they always
you know I used to fall for that okay
they'd say well what mineral is this now
we tell what the middle was and I'd go
three months I didn't hear from them so
I call them say hey Julie whatever
happened to Frank I haven't heard with
you guys well he did that he took that
mineral you said and three months later
he died
actually we've only taken that one
mineral he wasn't taking all 90. yeah
okay so you can't play that game well
which one is it no you take them all
okay it's one of those things where you
don't just put
um um
oil in your in your car you also have
transmission fluid you have brake fluid
you have antifreeze you have windshield
wiper fluid you understand what I'm
saying
you got to do the same thing for
yourself you can't just say well I just
put all in my car and the engine blew up
or did you did you have heavy grease in
there no did you have any antifreeze in
it no
um okay so that's you know you have to
do the whole thing
and you can't play that game of okay I'm
gonna take this and give up everything
else they're trying to save money and
they kill themselves
[Music]
okay thank you doc okay
all right thank you Jill now Dr Wallach
um I have Doug in California and he says
I'm anemic I don't know why how can I
best pump up my red blood cells I love
your show Dr Wallach
so do we know anything about him anyways
or anything like that oh sorry 175
pounds at five foot eight
and he is 52 years old anything else
that's it okay so I'm going on what we
know
he needs to get rid of all the bad stuff
no fried foods no processed Meats no
oils no glutens you can be supplementing
with five pounds of iron a day if you're
eating gluten you can't absorb any of it
it's all going in the toilet unless
they're constipating you a lot okay and
so there's something going on there with
his eating habits
okay he's got to get rid of all the bad
stuff get that book drone's cooking
about the bad foods 300 pages of safe
recipes and safe cooking methods and
then at uh let's see here 100
175 175 pounds I wanted to have two
healthy brand hard packs a month the
photos everything twice a day I want him
to have uh two bottles a month of the
msms and take three breakfasts eat lunch
at dinner time and that's going to help
him
um with his bone marrow which is very
important because that's where the red
blood cells are made in the bone marrow
and I also wanted to have the collagen
peptides and when we get two cancers a
month so I can take a scuba that was
morning drinks with this evening drink
um they have vitamin D three three of
those twice a day and he needs the uh
let's see here it'll be two vowels a
month and so we can absorb the minerals
and put them in uh his bones and so
forth but he's got to stay away from the
bad stuff gluten wheat run around oats
buckwheat phagopyrenes
uh carbonated drinks all that's got to
go and again
um this is where the good food bad food
list comes in in the in the book doctor
was cooking without the bad food it's
very important and we have of course the
rebound or sport shrink with 100
nutrients in it 75 minerals and 25
pounds amino acids
we have the healthy Bone and Joint pack
we have the healthy grain and heart pack
all these things have these multiples of
nutrients in there to cover every
nutritional need of the body but you
have to stay away from the bad stuff so
you can absorb them and this is a
lifetime deal this is not just until you
feel a little better and then you can
quit all this no no no no how long do
you need oxygen forever probably need
water forever how long you need the 90s
nutrients forever only you need to stay
away from the bad stuff forever if you
break that for everything anywhere in
that process it's going to cost you
to cost you high amounts of money you
know paying for medical care is going to
cost you
in years of your life
okay you can add 25 to 50 Health figures
your life or it can take away 25 to 50
years of your life depending on what you
do
all right thank you so much Dr Wallach
and let's go to the next town that is up
and Bobby go ahead and unmute yourself
hello thank you Dr Wallach and thank you
Rebecca in the in the team
um Dr while I have a question I have a
male he's 24 years of age
92 pounds
five feet
and he eats a lot of junk food he sleeps
most the day
and in three days he ate a big jar of
pickles
yeah well he's craving stuff and of
course
a jar of pickles I guarantee there's a
lot of salt in there and that was good
for him to taste that salt and and eat
the pickles because they have salt in
them
but you know to do that you know for one
week out of his life that's not enough
at uh 92 pounds he needs one Health
abandoned heart pack you know gotta give
her all the bad foods get a hold of that
book the doctor was cooking without the
bad foods 300 pages of safe recipes and
cooking methods and then he needs one
healthy band Heart pack per month a half
of those are in your breakfast have
those at dinner time one bottle a month
at the MSM is gonna take three breakfast
for dinner time
he needs let's see here two scoops a day
one at breakfast drink one dinner drink
of the collagen peptides
and then I also want him to use our
rebound or sports drink with 100
nutrients in it and his body weight he
could have one for sure maybe two but I
wouldn't take the second one after say
two o'clock in the afternoon because it
might keep him up all night or something
like that
but um highway 142 and I drink two of
those rebounds a day I popped the tops
in the cans when I'm at home and put
them in the refrigerator have one at
breakfast one like at maybe two o'clock
in the afternoon when I'm on the road I
use the sticks there's 30 sticks in a
box it's the same recipes okay it has
the
um 100 nutrients 75 minerals and of
course we also have the canister most of
these foreign countries they only let
the canister in they don't let the cans
in I only drink the cans at home on the
road I take this the sticks I don't even
take the canister on an airplane because
the guys who inspect everything they
near close everything tight enough and
wind up getting all that powder all over
everything
and so
I've been taking the 90 essential
nutrients
since I was nine years old a minimum of
twice a day I've been doing this for 75
years okay and it's one of those things
where I've only was sick three days when
I fell into a trench up in Canada okay
because they put a trench in a place
where it hadn't been before there were
no lights or just walking through the
woods and fell into that trench they
gave me IV antibiotics for three days
other than that I made it going out in a
couple of months I'll be 84 years old
and
up in those three days we were given the
IV antibiotics to prevent infection from
killing me from that wound from falling
in that hole guess what I've never been
on any prescription drugs I don't have
any diseases like habit pressure
diabetes arthritis I don't have heart
disease I don't have anything like
um
liver cirrhosis I don't have gallbladder
problems I don't have digestive problems
okay it's it's I don't have anemia this
is not difficult
okay I only have lost one tooth I was in
a fight in a mall where three guys tried
to take my packages away from me and of
course one of them paid the price the
other two ran away I did I did lose one
teeth but these are my own teeth I'm 84
years old and still have my own teeth
okay and that's because I've been taking
these 90 essential nutrients okay since
I was
um nine
all right thank you Dr Wallach for that
and all the information great questions
today now I am going to back to your
veterinarian hat Dr Wallach okay and we
have a large I believe he's a Mastiff
I'm not quite sure
um but he has gotten this bacterial
infection that is causing a runny black
or bloody stool
so what would your recommendation be
we've got a large dog about 75 pounds
um and I think he's only like seven
years old okay
well
um if they don't want to do the
antibiotic thing they we do have the
colloidal silver if you give them two
droppers full of colloidal silver under
his tongue in the morning uh in the
middle of the day and in the evening
before everybody goes to bed and that's
you know it's been used as an antibiotic
by humans for thousands and thousands
and thousands of years and it's safe
there's no alcohol in it anything like
that so the dog's not going to get drunk
and then
um I would also to support the immune
system make sure that um he has the
arthrodex
the arthradex is one scoop for 20 pounds
of body weight so I'd give them Four
Scoops even though it's a little bit
extra I'd give them Four Scoops okay the
answer to action is food every day and I
prefer the canned dog foods you know
like
um a can of dogs with all the vitamins
and minerals in it and the canned dog
foods they put
um how much of that dog food You're
supposed to feed a 100 pound dog a 75
pound dog a 50 pound dog and all that
kind of stuff so follow that that
schedule
and
um that's kind of where I would go with
that
I just got noticed he's also been
diagnosed with Lyme disease would you
add anything different to that
okay colloidal silver colloidal silver
collateral silver collateral silver
thank you thank you thank you
all right
um doctor well like the next question
has to do with blood pressure so this
individual is 43 years old
um 126 pounds
at five foot four
and she says that she her blood pressure
is always running really low like 90
over 52 is the number she writes here
I know for some people that's normal for
other people that's not normal
what would you recommend she has no
other health concerns
and she's amazing like she's drowsy or
wants to go to bed early or it was just
getting to that or her blood she says
when her blood pressure is running lower
she just has no energy
okay I would like to know what her blood
sugar is at that point when she has no
energy I want to know what her blood
sugar is if she has reactive
hypoglycemia does she have these
episodes like an hour or two after she
eats
are they having any time of the day if
they happen after she eats this reactive
hypoglycemia as the blood sugar drops
okay the blood pressure can drop along
with it
okay okay so she can she can figure that
out herself she can take her own blood
pressure she can take her own blood
sugar right
and so it's one of those things where
he's got to track that kind of stuff
but at um let's see here she's
um
126 pounds 126 pounds okay 126 pounds I
was looking at the wrong
box there 126 pounds
um I want her to have uh let's see here
uh two vowels a month of our sweetie so
he could take three of those twice a day
I want her to get two bottles a month of
her ultimate daily classic tablets three
words ultimate daily classic times we
can take three twice a day I want her to
have it 120 pounds one healthy rain and
heart pack a half a dose for everything
twice a day and uh let's see here also I
wanted to have one bottle a month again
the ultimate daily classic those three
names ultimate daily classic Talos take
three of those twice a day and that will
support healthy blood pressure healthy
blood flows or blocked arteries and then
of course the sweeties three of those
twice a day that's going to help her
manage blood sugar but she's got to stay
away okay from all the bad stuff and so
um
we need to find out what her blood sugar
runs when it's the gifts that that
sleep sleepy feeling okay I will
definitely get back with her on that get
that question answered because that's
that's very important when the blood
sugar drops energy drops well that's
what happens when people are driving
down the highway and they fall asleep at
the wheel and cross the center line
cause a head-on collision
let's have a glycemia you know so you
you find out oh it was an hour after
they had lunch or an hour after they had
dinner and they have a couple of soft
drinks and some candy and all that kind
of stuff all this sugar okay and then an
hour later their blood sugars
30 instead of 80. okay and they're
falling asleep
uh people fall asleep watching TV oh
yeah I had a big meal I just get drowsy
when I get a big meal and so I just stay
at home and watch TV and because I know
I'm gonna fall asleep on the couch an
hour after I eat well that's reactive
hypoglycemia and that's a nutritional
deficiency it's not a genetic thing it's
not an arm immune thing it's not
something that happens with age
it's a nutritional deficiency
all right well I know people that black
out Dr Wallach completely black out pass
out when their blood sugar hits 55. so
to hit 30 oh my goodness that's really
low
really low so talking about that
um I know some people that just have no
control over being able to stay awake I
mean they'll be going along doing their
way doing their thing and then all of a
sudden
they're fighting and sometimes can't
fight hard enough to stay awake no
matter where they're at or what they're
doing so like what you were talking
about when they're driving
it's a bad time to have reactive
hypoglycemia
and that's just those are those are
symptoms of having that reactive
hypoglycemia that's correct especially
after a meal you know when you have a
high carb meal like spaghetti something
like that or pancakes or breakfast
waffles
maybe for dinner time uh you have a big
piece of cake for dessert or something
like that and then you're watching TV
and like 30 minutes after you're
watching TV their elbow and hey wake up
you're missing a good part of the movie
here
already asleep
so those carbohydrates they can be
gluten free also right
I think that the low blood sugar
is due to sugar
okay
and so it's one of those things where if
you have a gluten issue
it might protect you from some of that
okay because you're not going to absorb
some of the sugar okay but you don't
want to be getting gluten okay you want
to be getting all 90 essential nutrients
so your body's able to do what it's
supposed to do and you do want to stay
away from all the bad stuff including
gluten wheat bun around oats and
buckwheat phagopyrines
again
um you want to add 25 to 50 Health years
your life you want to add 25 to 50
healthy years to the life of the people
you love
these are very easy details to take care
of
you don't need a doctor's permission to
take the 90 essential nutrients you
don't need a diet for the permission to
uh you know if you know you're going to
be driving don't be eating High
carbohydrate meals before you drive okay
because you are going to fall asleep
especially if you're deficient in those
nutrients get a hearing analysis
get hair analysis get the book rarest
review and cures and pay at page 272
chapters 10 11 tells you how to collect
the hair where to ship it because
there's certain nutrients there's very
specific nutrients that are missing when
you have reactive hypoglycemia and
people say which one are they which one
are they and I used to tell people
they'd run to the store and they buy
those two minerals and then two months
later they're dead
okay because they just took those two
minerals and left out the other
and 78 or 87 or whatever it is yeah
for you folks we've got to get all
Dr Wallace
more people and thank you so much for
joining us once again here on daily with
Doc so we'll see you tomorrow don't
forget the jaw uh uh don't read the job
that's right keep keep everything
everything good and strong so thank you
again Dr Wallach we will see you
tomorrow and I just want to thank all of
my co-hosts I have root on with me today
Ruth Owen Sanchez who is my technical
she makes thing ever make sure that
everything is going to where it's
supposed to with the stream we have
Heather Bowen who is my social media
expert making sure that information is
being shared around social media
um and also she's helping to monitor the
chats so if you've got questions that
you're bringing up on social media uh go
ahead bring those we have somebody
that's going to help me make sure all of
those questions get answered as well we
have Marilyn on with us today she has
been so diligent about putting
information in the chat so that you who
are live with us can take that
information and write it down because I
know Dr Wallach talks really fast and
having that information in the chat is
so very helpful and we have Miss Sherry
thank you so much Miss Sherry as she's
monitoring the waiting room to make sure
that everybody gets in on a timely
manner so that they don't miss anything
and also helping to keep track of that
chat so again my name is Becca dukes and
as the hostess of this program with
Bailey with Doc it is my honor and
privilege to be able to create this
resource to help you help yourself
go to our website and you'll be able to
find all of the replays from our
programming with the new website we do
have a couple day delay as we're getting
everything situated and getting it onto
the website but we do have our previous
shows and from also our previous
broadcasts that we have held over the
last over two and a half years which I
am super excited to have that there
there's also a store that has the
products Dr Wallach mentioned but again
get back with the person who shared this
program with you if there's nobody to
think then feel free to use our website
use our contact us and we will get you
in contact with a certified holistic
health coach to help you get the
information you need so that you can do
more than just survive but actually
Thrive until next time bye for now
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]